hey youtubers it's Charlie so a whole
bunch of new flash footage so I'm just
gonna do breakdown of the new stuff now
a lot of this is repeated from the last
trailer so I'm just gonna do like the
patty spivot some of the things that we
haven't seen before
he is an unstoppable demon and your
world is in danger you created a breach
a portal
she got do that anymore father you do
realize the metahumans have super powers
right I may not have powers but I want
to stop them central city believes in
the flash so I
mommy you're gonna have to catch me
show time if you guys aren't familiar
with patty spivot she's actually been
around since the late 70s but like a lot
of classic characters the Jeff John
Slater rework too like like the ropes
for instance patty spivot debuted as a
small minor character became miss flash
for a little while like she got flash
powers for a little while then kind of
went away didn't turn into a big thing
when Geoff Johns brought her on he
reimagined the character completely and
she ended up providing a lot of critical
assistance to the flash in the lead up
to flashpoint she had this really
awesome run-in with Professor zoom with
a Oh Bart Thawne where he you know I
mean they're a couple powers that he has
in the comics that we didn't see on the
show like he can control his age so he
reagent
right in front of her eyes to his normal
age as he's getting ready to kill her
the rest of the flash is show up save
her life
it's a lot like having to watch Cisco
died during the flash season one you
know even though they took it back it's
still stung a little bit but even patty
spivot during that storyline was a
relatively minor character she was kind
of a late comer to the adventure after
flashpoint in the new 52 universe they
made some huge changes to the characters
so patty spivot became a regular inside
the central city police department and
she and Barry were living together as
boyfriend and girlfriend
he wasn't connected to Iris West the
same way he had been in the past and I
almost forgot to mention for a second
time she gets flash powers but she takes
the persona of hot pursuit during the
flashpoint storyline she and Bart Allen
we go to the 30th century to try and
stop Brainiac so they get caught up in
their own little adventure really the
mission with patty spivot in the comics
is to introduce a female to Barry
Allen's life that can be a part of the
action without only being a love
interest because that's kind of the
perception for iris West for a lot of
the comics like you only think of her
when you're thinking of Barry Allen the
intention with patty spivot is just to
make a much more complete character so I
think that's why a lot of people were
excited when she was announced for the
TV show it was really after the
producers started talking about what
they're doing with her on the TV show
you know how that's gonna be different
from the comics that got me really
excited I think she's gonna be the most
fun new female character next to Jessie
quick now just to be clear there's a lot
of new female characters coming on the
flash the patty spivot is gonna be one
of the few main cast members meaning
that her arc is gonna be much bigger
than Jessie quick
anytime they announce a billion new
characters everyone gets a little bit
worried because it's like how's everyone
getting get all the screen time a lot of
them are only going to be in a couple
episodes they're only getting
minor arcs Wally West for instance
probably not gonna be Kid Flash till the
end of the season so patty spivot this
is kind of like the way they teased her
obviously they didn't give away a lot of
spoilers they said she's gonna be Joe s
new partner and as you've seen the
trailer she demands to join his task
force a group of police officers to deal
with all the crazies that are coming
from earth-2 it's a nice mirror for what
Quentin Lance is doing over on arrow
he's reassembling the vigilante task
force so they said patty spivot has
mysterious but very important reasons
like very very solid reasons for wanting
to join Joe's task force she has a
really fun personality and she's really
into the science of everything so she
and Barry are gonna be like the perfect
match for each other if you didn't get
it from season one they they didn't
really go into it really deeply but
Barry is a forensic scientist so he's
actually very very smart not quite as
smart as Cisco and Caitlin but you know
be get the idea very smart patty spivot
also going to be very very smart it just
I feel like all the fun stuff happens at
STAR Labs so if you want new characters
to also be perceived as fun they have to
be able to keep up with all the smart
characters at STAR Labs as of right now
in the comics they have not reintroduced
patty spivot yet post convergence so it
wouldn't be surprised if what they're
doing on the TV show influences that
just like like in the same way that
Felicity Smoak not a big comic book
character before arrow and now the
Felicity Smoak of the comics looks a lot
more like felicity of the TV show the
same thing is going on in the Marvel
verse like the TV and the movie
characters are starting to influence the
way they write the comics the really
good news I know everybody loves new
footage is it like every single week
leading up to the flash will probably it
like a little bit more footage now most
of the footage we get is from the first
two episodes and there's only so much
they can show us without you know being
super spoilery so don't be surprised if
next week when they post a promo a lot
of the footage is the same that we just
saw really there's like one big thing
that they keep talking about that we
haven't seen yet and that is zoom now
the way they described him is he's gonna
be more like a monster I mean they even
stayed in the trailer Jay Garrick says
he's a monster but literally he's going
to look like a monster
compared to eobard thawne now I know
most of you guys read the comics and I
did a video explaining the difference
between zoom and professor zoom that you
know two completely different reverse
flashes now the TV show also gonna make
some changes so whenever we do see him
I'll just I'll explain again
not only are they changing some things
about the identity of the character
they're changing the way that he's done
on-screen like that that completely from
the ground up the way he looks
whenever they started talking about
zooms costume about how I was gonna look
a lot a lot more CG it was gonna look
WAY Trippier than the reverse flashes
costume and he was gonna be this hulking
speed demon all I could think about was
the Tasmanian devil like from looney
tunes in yellow paint obviously Tony
Todd is gonna be doing zooms voice so
it's gonna be freakin amazing but we're
really not gonna meet him up close in
the flesh til the episode titled the
flash of two worlds I actually I don't
know which number that is but it's
probably somewhere in the first four
episodes most of the really big
characters like Wally West all those
people will meet them in the first four
episodes but essentially what's going on
like they did they did tease this
because you can kind of see when we're
on the earth too plain you see like the
background it looks like everything's
been destroyed the portal that Barry
opens between earth one and earth two
allows him to get through now I know
something you'll be like wait a minute
hold the phone
zoom is supposed to be way faster than
all the other flashes so why can't he do
the same things that Barry can do in the
really trippy looking earth to scenes it
looks like everything has been destroyed
like this is this is STAR Labs of Earth
two so it seems like the only reason the
zoom wouldn't be able to do that on his
own is because he's destroyed the
technology that they need and it has
nothing to do with what hunter zolomon
did in the comics so forget about that
version of the character some of you
guys have already requested videos for
specific characters like atom smasher if
there are any others that you guys want
to see in the next couple weeks just let
me know in the comments below because we
finally got the trailer I'm actually
starting my reverse flash ring giveaway
- all you have to do dinner that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video what's gonna happen next is is
there's a Doctor Who series 9 prequel
that just dropped that I need to do a
video for then after that I'll do a Q&A
video where I'll announce the winner if
everything ends up going as smoothly as
I hope that it will then I'll just
continue to giveaway reverse-flash rings
and you know until we get to episode 1
you guys can let me know though which
female character are you most excited to
see in season 2 you know I'll say right
now based on some of the stuff that
Daniel Pennebaker has been saying makes
me feel like they're not gonna do killer
frost so fair warning try not to get too
hyped up about that
so make you guys wait for more flash
arrow stuff you can click here for the
last trailers that just dropped and you
can click here for the Marvel
Jessica Jones teaser trailer thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys this weekend